u.s job market that sizzled all summer
cooling down in a big way the economy
added just 235 000 jobs in august way
under wall street expectations and much
lower than the large job gain scene in
both july and june bankrate senior
economist analyst mark hamrick says
rising covet cases likely play a role
people are dialing back as this pandemic
continues to rage in new ways and this
is having an impact on the economy
hamrick says hiring in many industries
dropped last month as americans ate out
less and canceled trips the unemployment
rate is now at 5.2 percent
come next week more than a hundred
thousand claimants will get their very
last unemployment payments federal
benefits set to end this weekend as joe
moeller shows us there are resources for
people out there looking for a job
we think about a hundred thousand
of the 140 000 or so that are currently
getting benefits
will see their benefits
the director of dieter alisa capareta
says the time has come for the extra
weekly federal benefits or 300 dollars
to come to an end in addition to some
extension programs and the pua program
there are more resources available right
now for people who are looking to find
that right fit of a job kefirata says
claimants can go to employeenb.gov for
help you can tap into the resources that
are available so help with a resume help
with training how to do a job interview
there are job
jobs listed there that
you know employers are hiring right now
the workforce connection one stop career
center is getting busy with benefits
ending a lot of people are concerned
about you know how they're going to
support themselves and their family joe
sharp is the project director of the
career center we provide free no cost
resources for people to get connected to
employers at this location near
charleston and jones people can get help
with resume building and training for a
new career i do expect that we'll see
some increase of people
not only because of the benefits of
ending but people now since the pandemic
have really started to explore different
options when it comes to careers joe
mohler 8 news now joe thank you
claimants on the ui program will still
receive benefits but without those extra
weekly benefits kirsten